[Musique]
oh
la vie dans toute sa splendeur l'être
humain en devenir
[Musique]
plus qu'une échographie la transe parise
à sion est une méthode d'imagerie
inédite elle dévoile le foetus comme
jamais auparavant
[Musique]
devenu translucide l'anatomie
embryonnaire se dévoile
on visualise la peau les muscles les
nerfs des vaisseaux sanguins
tout du foetus peut être observé
cette prouesse s'effectue entre la 6e et
la 14e semaine de gestation
l'embryon mesure quelques 5 cm et fait 3
cm d'épaisseur
au delà la transe parise à sion atteint
ses limites
le contour se déforme la précision des
images diminue
cette spectaculaire transparence est
d'abord rendue possible grâce à des
seuls va indique id capable d'éliminer
le gras de la membrane cellulaire
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
l'utilisation de tels se levant préserve
la cellule ne l'alter pas
une fois la cédule devenu translucide
ont fait appel à des anticorps six
défenseurs du système immunitaire
d'abord parce qu'on peut lui attacher
une molécule fluorescente
mais aussi parce que d'anticorps c'est
reconnaître et se fixer à n'importe
quelles cellules du corps humain
ainsi pour voir des céline d'intérêt
celle du système nerveux par exemple il
suffit de choisir lé anticorps capables
de le cibler et de s'y fixer
l'utilisation simultanée de plusieurs
anticorps permet de visualiser
différentes cellules en même temps idéal
pour distinguer les nerfs sensitifs des
nerfs moteurs par exemple
[Musique]
oh
ce voyage en haute résolution a pour but
nous aider notamment à mieux comprendre
le développement de leur brillant et le
rythme auquel les cellules de chaque
organe prolifèrent
dans un avenir rapproché il servira
d'outil diagnostic lors de fausse couche
qui pour la plupart se produisent lors
du premier trimestre
[Musique]